this will be the new face of british
greatness abroad
post-brexit hopes the government a
national flagship
ministers and businesses will be able to
swap the land for the seas
as they negotiate with foreign
governments and court investors
i think such a trade platform would be
very helpful in this i mean this country
already spends vast amounts of money
in showcasing itself around the world at
uh you know various uh international
events
this would be a supplement to that to
show the world that we're here
we're open we're free we're a global
trading nation
come and do business with us i name the
ship britannia
the last ship of this kind was the royal
yacht britannia
which was decommissioned in 1997
becoming a tourist attraction
its replacement would be crewed by the
navy and is expected to be in service
for around 30 years
but could come with a price tag of 200
million pounds people who remember the
old boat
suggest to me that it achieved really
very little in terms of
trade there's no evidence that what we
need now is a
boat to increase our trade those times
are long gone
where all you needed to win
international trade was to entertain a
few people on a boat
number 10 has said the vessel will be
designed and built in the uk
with a focus on green technology the
government says it wants to drive a
renaissance in british shipbuilding
so places like portsmouth could be in
the running to deliver construction
which could start next year and is
expected to take three years to complete
the ship will of course need to be
called something we found
some suggestions princess kate's loving
him
britannia mark too the ladybug
the duke of edinburgh has been mentioned
as a contender for the name
not only did the prince sail on
britannia around the world he helped
with the design
too unlike its predecessor the role of
this new flagship will be to help the uk
secure deals
as an independent trading nation a boat
the prime minister hopes
will boost and befit britain's place on
the world stage
becky kotchel sky news portsmouth